[Music]
and we are broadcasting tonight from Las
Vegas now we're going to explain exactly
why later tonight but first massive
bombshell breaking news developments in
the biggest scandal ever involving
Russia now we'll continue to do what the
corrupt lying mainstream media will not
do because we will prove tonight they
are complicit and what is a huge
cover-up we're going to explain how the
Clintons the Obama administration
created a massive national security
crisis by handing Vladimir Putin of
Russia and the Russians 20% of America's
uranium which is the foundational
material to make nuclear weapons and
tonight we will explain in detail who
and how many people knew that the
Russians had infiltrated of America's
uranium market and how all of this was
all before the uranium one deal that's
the subject of tonight's mini monologue
by John Solomon Sarah Carter their
investigative reporters they're the ones
we've been breaking this Russia nuclear
scandal wide open now they're going to
be joining us in just a little bit and
guess what they have new stunning
information tonight here's the headline
from John Solomon's new report it says
Bill Clinton sought States permission to
meet with Russian nuclear director
during Obama uranium decision now
according to John Solomon while Bill
Clinton was getting ready to collect
$500,000 for a speech in Moscow double
as normal speaking faith
he was also seeking State Department
clearance to meet with a key official
with the Russian nuclear energy company
involved in this uranium 1 deal Sarah
Carter also reporting quote US
consulting firms with ties to the
Clintons lobbied on behalf of Russia's
nuclear giant now Sarah tonight is
reporting that an American lobbying firm
that they took millions of dollars from
a Russian state-run nuclear energy
corporation while at the same time
providing pro bono services to the
Clinton Global Initiative and that's not
all these payments took place in 2010
and 2011 well that's when Hillary
Clinton was the Secretary of State and
helped approve this uranium 1 deal now
earlier today the president weighed in
heavily on this Russian collusion
national security crisis and this is
important watch this if
the mainstream media would cover the
uranium scandal and that Russia has 20%
of a uranium for whatever reason and a
lot of people understand what those
reasons may be I think that's your
Russia story that's your real Russia
story not a story where they talk about
collusion and there was none it was a
hoax your real Russia story is uranium
and how they got all of that uranium
vast percentage of what we have that is
to me one of the big stories of the
decade thank god the president is
speaking out he is absolutely correct
and it is what we have been telling you
now for months and months Democrats the
fake news media have been outright lying
to you non-stop for over a year about
Russia and what's really going on now
they have been creating distractions
feigning outrage moral outrage pushing
black helicopter conspiracy theories
despite all the evidence that is in and
they had no evidence on their side now
this is all an attempt to conceal now
the real truth from you the American
people about Russia about Vladimir Putin
and what is now his successful efforts
to infiltrate the American uranium
market now all the evidence of
corruption and criminal conduct and one
of the biggest scandals in American
history has been sitting right in front
of the Democrats right in front of the
media but because they're rigid
ideologues they're choosing to ignore it
and by the way that makes them complicit
in putting all of us in America in
danger now there's new information that
we have tonight builds on John Solomon
and Sarah Carter's reporting from
earlier this week now here are the
highlights of what we know now and why
this is such a massive scandal now back
in 2009 2009 the FBI discovered real
evidence in the form of documents emails
financial records from eyewitnesses and
FBI informants that had infiltrated on
behalf of the FBI the Russian nuclear
industry and meeting with these
officials all on behalf they're doing
this on behalf of
vitomir Putin and Moscow what were they
doing they were engaging in bribery the
FBI knew him kickbacks the FBI knew it
money laundering the FBI knew it
extortion and other types of
racketeering and all sorts of other
criminal conduct so why was all this
happening because Vladimir Putin had a
goal he set out to corner America's
uranium market now sadly because of the
Obama administration
he got Barack Obama Hillary Clinton Eric
Holder and all these others because of
their stupidity their ineptness and
their corruption Vladimir Putin
succeeded now despite knowing all of
this in 2009 when 2010 comes around
while the Russians were carrying out
this bribery scheme and they've been
doing it for over a year and the FBI
knew over a year including Hillary
Clinton and many others they ended up
still approving this corrupt uranium one
deal that gave twenty percent of
America's uranium to Russia
there's also another massive part of
this story involving the Clintons now
the hill and circa news.com have also
reported that the FBI has evidence this
includes eyewitness accounts that the
Russian nuclear officials were funneling
millions and millions of dollars to the
Clinton Foundation while Hillary was
actually serving as Secretary of State
and personally signing off on the
uranium one deal and according to both
explosive reports the Obama
administration they hid the evidence of
this Russian bribery plot from Congress
there's an FBI informant he wanted to
tell Congress he wants to share with
Congress today and he wants to tell the
American people well what's happened
he's been threatened with lawsuits and
retribution of all kinds you the
American people all of us should be
outraged over what has happened here and
by the way we all need to demand answers
now the Clintons and the Obama
administration have created what is
nothing short of a clear and present
danger to those responsible I say this
you need to be held accountable you need
to be prosecuted to the fullest extent
of the law we're also learning that back
in 2015 now this is five years after
this uranium deal one deal was completed
the New York Times they reported that
the Russian nuclear company uranium one
was actually a
sporting yellowcake uranium outside of
the country to Canada even though it
didn't have a license so basically
understand this the Obama administration
President Obama Hillary Clinton Eric
Holder what they allowed in this deal
was Vladimir Putin to export yellowcake
uranium which could be used to create
nuclear warheads and by the way what he
does with it does anybody know by the
way is he giving it to North Korea is he
giving it to Iran nobody has any idea
this is a direct national security
threat to every man woman and child not
only in this country but around the
world
and as we have been telling you finally
the Senate Judiciary Committee has now
announced they are launching an
investigation into what top obama
administration officials knew about the
evidence surrounding this corrupt
uranium one deal there are several key
players that need to be halt before
congress forced to testify it needs to
be under oath they need to explain why
they gave one of America's biggest
adversaries control of 20% of our
uranium supply then of course this
former attorney General Eric Holder well
he was ahead of the DOJ they oversee the
FBI the FBI knew in 2009 he also sat on
the committee that approved the Iranian
one deal there's no way that holder did
not know what Russia was trying to do so
it's time for mr. holder to start
talking and answering questions and then
of course these names will all sound
familiar you have the Deputy Attorney
General today rod Rosen seen he's now of
course he's second under the Department
of Justice under our Attorney General
Jeff Sessions and then we have Andrew
McCabe they were actually oversaw the
FBI's operation into the Russian bribery
case so they clearly were well aware
about what was taking place so they need
to be put under oath they need to tell
us why were they silent then there's now
the Special Counsel Robert Muller he was
serving as the FBI director back in 2009
when the Russian bribery and money
laundering all began Muller - he should
not be leading any probes into Russian
collusion guess why he should be
answering questions about the real
Russian scandal and he should be put
under oath now the
of Rodd Rosenstein neil mccabe robert
muller frankly is inexcusable there's a
massive conflict of interest they've
told nobody and by the way in no way can
they be trusted to conduct a fair
investigation into anything that
involves Russia when they were involved
in this massive scandal so it's time for
them to literally either resign get out
of the way or come public with
everything they know as of my position I
think they've been compromised
especially when it comes to Russia now
it's well past time for many of them to
go these people are corrupt they've been
compromised and finally you got the
liberal mainstream media now for years
we've been telling you journalism is
dead they've been lying to you the
American people for well over a year
about Russia Russia Russia the press has
been spreading fake news conspiracy
theories almost 24/7 non-stop now why
why are they so silent in this case
because they've wanted to create as many
distractions as possible to hide the
truth now here are just some of the
examples of the liberal mainstream media
in action just to remind you take a look
but first we want to start with this
week in Russia gate it is as if there
are no shoes on the Trump Human
Centipede
that are not about Russia Russia Russia
Russia this cloud about collusion with
Russia will hang over him no matter
where he stand it certainly feels like
we're in the opening stages of a
devastating political chapter in
American history evidence is mounting
for the president's meddling in the
Russia probe Tom Friedman said the
election hacking is at the caliber of a
Pearl Harbor or a 9/11 to agree with
that I completely agree with that Donald
Trump now since at the threshold of
impeachment
I personally think it's over I don't
think there's anything that can be done
that can stop this at this point
cacophony this gushing of Lies problems
questions chaos that will stop this
presidency in its tracks you told The
Washington Post last week that quote
there's a smell of treason in the air
when it comes to this investigation a
lot of people are afraid to use the T
word treason but in the end that's what
people are investing
it does look like collusion it does look
like he's listening to Putin more than
he has American intelligence and frankly
I've never seen that before the corrupt
rigid radical left-wing ideological
media and of course their love of all
things Clinton they never investigated
how did Bill Clinton double his speaking
fees in Moscow and how at the time was
he praising the steel wall in Moscow and
the money flowing up to a hundred and
forty five million dollars to the
Clinton Foundation she's signing off on
the deal by the way where did that money
really come from now the media has so
much concern about Russia Russia Russia
Russia Russia and Russia influencing
American the dangers of Vladimir Putin
well this could end up now being the
biggest breaches of American national
security in our history and after them
telling us how dangerous Putin is and
how dangerous Russia is this is beyond
media malpractice this is an agenda the
media does not care about the truth they
don't care about facts they don't care
about investigative reporting radical
rigid left-wing ideologues who lie to
you on a regular basis and are hell-bent
on one thing and one thing only
destroying president Trump it's why even
after John Solomon Sarah Carter's
reporting they have ignored this massive
scandal imagine for just a second if
Donald Trump ever gave twenty percent of
America's uranium to Vladimir how would
they be reacting and he got money kicked
back to the Trump foundation now
according to the media Research Center
all Network newscasts they haven't
touched this story it's like a complete
United blackout the MRC found that CNN
devoted a whopping 19 seconds to it this
is pathetic and it proves a point I've
been making now since 2007 media in
America is dead and in this case
involving national security they are
complicit totally and completely
complicit in this scandal unbelievable